bienvenue sur tv fils si vous venez de
nous rejoindre une nouvelle édition du 7
8 sport bonfante soir wilfried au menu
de ce 7 8 sport du rugby tout d'abord
nous reviendrons évidemment sur la
qualification pour les demi finales de
playoffs de rambouillet et nous
essayerons de comprendre la recette du
succès un des clubs évinois dans les
phases finales
je recevrai également arnaud parents le
président du club d'ultimate de plaisir
avant le zéro point ce tournoi annuel
plaisir whaou la crème du frisbee noah
est d'ailleurs s'affrontent tout
simplement
et puis comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission et frites tous les résultats
du week-end et on va commencer par le
rugby le territoire yvelinois se porte
plutôt bien en la matière oui c'est la
traditionnelle période des phases de
playoffs les phases finales après la
saison régulière et cette saison c'est
un bon cru en 2013 puisque cinq club
yvelinois sont qualifiés pour les
playoffs dont rambouillet et plaisir et
et les coachs et directeur technique
nous font l'honneur et le plaisir d'être
de ce soir parmi nous le directeur
technique de rambouillet sport rugby
alain sous la boue ce raout bonjour vous
êtes accompagné d'eric david où
l'entraîneur des seniors de l'équipe
première qui a fait ce bel exploit hier
mon cerveau pour ce soir et côté côté
plaisir wa évidemment philippe behar
l'entraîneur des seniors bonsoir look
bon soir alors évidemment là vous avez
vous avez fait un bel exploit après une
saison invaincus j'imagine que
l'entraîneur et le directeur technique
son sens satisfait de leurs joueurs
quatorze matches 14 victoires de spawn
us va aller mieux et c'était une belle
fête en plus il ya un cessez le feu
ce n'était pas un exploit a normalement
c'était une équipe à notre portée
le gros problème c'était là le jeu qui a
par moment où ont primé sur le jeu et on
s'est un petit peu mais lâchez les
pédales paraît ce temps on n'a pas
toujours maîtrisé mais le résultat est
là il est large donc on va pouvoir
continuer dès la semaine prochaine
12 victoires en 12 rencontres 14 14
pardon j'ai oublié de pasqua
comment c'est possible aux joueurs toute
acquise pratiquement avec le bonus bonus
offensif oui les bonus offensif
c'est tout ce qu'on espère bonifier un
secret où on a remis les choses un petit
peu s'élance à l'ordre il ya sept ans
jeudi avait il y avait un passé
rugbystique à rambouillet mais il y
avait peut-être à structurer davantage
le jeu y compris le jeu de trois-quarts
il y avait beaucoup plus de percussion
que de contournement le rugby c'est la
bagarre dans le combat mais c'est aussi
le contournement est dans ce
contournement là les joueurs n'étaient
pas assez performant aujourd'hui sont le
plus performant maintenant il faut qu'on
arrive à allier les deux comme il faut
en fonction de l'adversaire
hier on n'a pas toujours joué en tenant
compte du rapport de force réel
oui c'était face à fontenay aux roses à
ce quart de finale de playoffs qui était
donc du côté du stade du vieux moulin
rambouillet une victoire qui vous
permettait d'accéder à la division
d'honneur donc au championnat de france
le contrat est rempli je vous propose de
regarder le récit de ce match dès le
coup d'envoi rambouillet veut marquer
son territoire
les verts mettent plus d'intensité à
l'impact et perfore le premier rideau
fontenaisiens vous obtiennent une
pénalité transformée par camille mairi à
la 20e minute de jeu le même camille
manioc riz profite d'un cadrage d'école
de match durant et phil dent
dans un stade du vieux moulin chauffé à
blanc les rambolitains envoient du jeu
au large
au près tout y passe il mène logiquement
à la pause 13 heures
retour des vestiaires l'emprise rambo
liten s'accentue au fil des minutes le
deuxième essai est un modèle de relance
de maxime kaboré le centre passe en
revue cinq joueurs composé
1 0 après la transformation de
l'excellent camille maillot riz auteur
d'un 4 sur 5 au pied et même à 13 contre
15 après deux cartons blancs
les joueurs d'éric david ou sont
euphoriques la muraille rambo liten est
infranchissable
il ajoute un quatrième essai en fin de
match par l'intermédiaire de romain
bausch man score final 31 3 la montée en
division d'honneur s'illumine de
championnat de france est validé tous
rambouillet que savoure on a bien entamé
le match on a marqué très tôt
pour ma part j'ai concrétisé les points
les pompiers rapidement ce qui nous ce
qui nous a fait ce qui nous a mis dedans
rapidement et est le plus important
c'est qu'on a été solidaires aujourd'hui
et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous a
tenus si on a tenu bon toute la saison
comme ça et aujourd'hui on est une
équipe à rambouillet c'est plus
important pendant le sujet alain je
vouvoyais hocher la tête vous êtes
n'être pas totalement d'accord avec
votre est liée non non non c'est le demi
mêlée qui qui prend le petit côté et le
soutien ne vient pas le soutien ne doit
pas attendre loin il doit se rapprocher
très vite du porteur de balle reçue et
donc qu'ils ont joué quelques fois il
n'y a pas que cet exemple là c'est pas
le meilleur peut être prendre tout seul
aller au contact tout seul alors qu'on
avait s'était promis de ne pas le faire
de faire circuler davantage la balle de
jouer plus collectif et la halle envie
de bien faire et envie de s'engager
ils ont mis beaucoup trop de physique
par rapport à ce qu'on a que deux
possibilités et on doit être on doit
être capable d'alterner le contournement
de la percussion ce qui m'a marqué sur
ce match eric c'est peut-être la
gourmandise des joueurs il ya eu parfois
des touches alors qu'ils étaient réduits
à 13 contre 15 des touche vite jouée des
transformations au 25 mai 30 mètres
assez facile qui n'ont pas été tentés
ça a été c'est un peu un chignon c'est
là où ils n'ont pas su gérer justement
c'est au moment du match il ya en
afrique et numérique
la chaleur les premières chaleurs on
sait bien c'est chaud il ya heureusement
on se met à jouer vite et donc on va
faire souffler les coéquipiers donc
prenez premier point de son temps à
aller se placer en touche essentielle en
courant prési faire respirer l'équipe
est là on s'affole et on se met tous
sont lancés alors qu'on en a flotté
numérique
ils vont nous faire mentir il marque un
essai à 13 contre 15 1
quels conseils vous aurez à donner
philippe je me tourne vers vous
l'habitué des playoffs un petit peu il
est avec un carton pareil 31,3 après une
saison presque parfaite invaincu c'est
quand même impressionnant
ah oui ou non mais je ne permettrai pas
donner des conseils des gens qu'on
réussit une saison comme ça je vais
rester à ma place nous on n'a pas mis
autant de bonus offensif cette année bon
après c'est vrai que ce qui a été dit
sur l'alternance dans le jeu est tout à
fait réelle et c'est la vérité quel que
soit le niveau
et justement cette dynamique de
victoires qui est présente à rambouillet
l'est un peu moins sur la fin de saison
un plaisir puisque là vous vous perdez
contre le dernier lors de la dernière
journée justement de championnat avant
de passer tout juste à domicile c'est
ouais il ya une dynamique différente
d'il ya eu un relâchement
la qualification acquise un peu le match
de district avait été un très bon match
on a fait un match à domicile contre les
bords de marne qui était le moyen vous y
étiez présent d'ailleurs
et puis on va perdre chez
l'avant-dernier mon petit membre mais en
mettant pas les ingrédients qu'il
fallait en particulier dans le combat
pour pour montrer que on est une équipe
qualifiée en championnat de france et
que c'était bon ce jour là c'était
inadmissible et je crois que les joueurs
l'ont entendu et j'espère que ça va leur
rester dans la tête pour qu'il présente
un autre visage particulier en 32e et
alors là cette semaine à l'entraînement
à dans les deux clubs
que ça soit rambouillet voix plaisir
quel va être le mot d'ordre ça va être
motivation sur motivation courage
cohésion du groupe peut-être qu'on a
l'habitude de le faire
on va revoir ce qui n'a pas bien
fonctionné dimanche et puis remettre
dans le bon sens dont le certaines
actions qui nous ont pas tout à fait
plus d'un an à la voyez les motivations
moi je crois qu'elle y est lié on n'a
jamais eu à ryadh axé là-dessus
d'ailleurs il est là une héroïne trop
j'ai été dans le couloir au moment des
dernières paroles et je pense que
certains ont peut-être on en peut être
un petit peu rajouté
on a joué plutôt sur la réflexion sur le
jeu la motivation ni son génie de l'eau
mais au contraire il faut maîtriser
davantage certains temps forts on aurait
dû prendre de pénalité sans problème
faire reposer les joueurs on ne l'a pas
fait mais bon on va recadrer ça et je
pense que l'ensemble de des joueurs
comprendra tout à fait qu'il s'agit de
jouer encore plus collectif et plus
juste mais c'est difficile de faire
passer un message auprès de joueurs
lorsqu'ils sont invaincus comme ça est
il se voit peut-être même trop
la difficulté de l'art est toujours vrai
mais bon on a quand même beaucoup
d'arguments pour justifier nos
interventions n'ayez pas peur
l'argument c'est quoi vous restaurer
sert prochain match si vous écoutez
malgré ces au président c'est sûr que
sont là je crois qu'il s'agit sont
conscients ils ont envie de bien faire
mais ils doivent maintenant apprendre
vite très vite pour ne pas louper une
marche
il pourrait le regretter par la suite on
a quand même quelque chose à faire on
voudrait qu'un passer quelques tours à
partir du 12 mai un champion de france
c'est pas en commençant à être classés
4e et d'île de france l'a donc d'image
mais encore retroussé les manches et
honfleur encore retourné de la chair
fraîche quand on dit au charbon comme on
l'a fait hier et qui voit là et après un
peu plus de tête froide un peu plus de
sérénité et je pense qu'il ya pas de
raison qui n'a pas le même enjeu d'image
prochaine et les gars seront peut-être
certainement pu libérer et de votre côté
fini pas plaisir cette semaine comment
comment ça va se passer à l'entraînement
sachant que vous allez beaucoup de
blessés il ya cette défaite qui reste en
travers de la gorge
de rassembler tous les to les valides
pour les faire travailler ensemble on a
un effectif qui est très court beaucoup
de blessés des joueurs en fin de saison
qu'ils sont fatigués qu'ils mettent plus
l'énergie qui mettaient en début de
saison comme on n'a pas des très gros
gabarit c'est difficile à ce niveau là
contre des équipes très très forte
physiquement donc on va essayer de se
reposer puis de s'appuyer sur la
réalisation la conquête les lancements
derrière essayer d'être précis et puis
l'engagement fini ça sera pas dimanche
parce que je pense que c'est pas la
peine deux semaines avant de se montrer
trop dans le chou on aurait du mal
aurait du mal à nier 22 joueurs sinon
dimanche prochain surtout que la réserve
aussi qualifié puisqu'elle a fini
première de poule et juhasz 16e aussi de
chats persans si c'est le cas dans les
deux clubs et non que vous en plus vous
jouez un poids lourd puisque c'est rouen
qui qui se profile on joue une équipe on
se demande ce qu'elle fait là quand on
voit l'effectif les joueurs la moitié
enfin c'est cuit joueurs internationaux
de leurs pays respectifs d'europe ou
d'ailleurs
donc bon c'est une équipe qui a les
cadres l'ambition qu'avec un des gros
moyens financiers 4 à 5 fois notre
budget bon qui qui va peut-être pas nous
prendre au sérieux at il est de votre
côté ça sera donc nemours ce week-end
aussi parce que vous enchaînez qu'elle a
réservé 2 premières très bien on suivra
donc toutes ces prouesses et donc ses
matches à enjeux à venir ce week-end du
côté de rambouillet et de plaisir
puisque les deux latéraux rers contre
son radeau ici à domicile date et
horaire ils ont envoyé les horaires pour
la réserve la semaine dernière ni zain
qui jouait à 15 heures mais je suppose
que tout va changer qui rectifier ça y
est c'est certainement très présente
pour la réserve et zéro pour la première
et un niveau concerne même chose 15
heures la première et la réserve joue à
mantes-la-jolie contre evreux a trait à
30 a renvoyé au plaisir il va falloir
choisir pour après jour de l'an du
département choix sera difficile merci à
vous trois messieurs anthony on parle de
vtt maintenant oui cette année de titre
régional de vtt se jouer sur la colline
et l'encours et dans des conditions très
difficiles suite aux intempéries de ces
dernières semaines
au programme de la boue sur les bosses
et encore de la boue dans la forêt 183
coureurs
est à l'assaut de la colline elancourt
ce week-end pour le titre régional de
vtt ufolep
au programme trois tours de 8 km un
dénivelé positif de 164 m et un départ à
couper le souffle
dès les premiers tours de roue les
coureurs devaient faire face à la mode
de la colline où les plus forts
pourcentages atteignent 18 % il devait
ensuite s'extraire des passages en forêt
encore très humide
bref un combat de tous les instants sur
24 km c'était compliqué partout il
fallait bien gérer mais il y avait une
partie très collante très boueuse vers
l'antenne où il est une descente très
sélective où il fallait passer à pied
mais pas trop le choix
et du coup c'est vrai que c'est s
étaient cités difficiles crevaison panne
de dérailleur chaîne cassée les abandons
se comptent par dizaines
la faute à un tracé extrêmement doué
pour s'imposer il fallait partir en
costaud à l'image de l'expérimentée
henri weber titre i chez les seniors en
fait j'ai attaqué au bout de la deuxième
contre le bitume ce que je voulais
vraiment partir tout seul
géré ma course et pas me regarder les
anars que adversaire qui était derrière
après ce marathon passer la ligne est un
soulagement et leur ravitaillement à la
buvette plutôt salvateur place désormais
à l'ultimate puisque ce week-end le
traditionnel tournoi annuel du club
d'ultimate de plaisir a lieu le zéro
open et arnaud parents le président du
club plaisir roi nous a rejoint bonsoir
vous tout à fait mouche comme anthony
alors expliquez nous un petit peu le
principe du temps je vais commencer en
vous donnant des cadeaux que le match du
tournoi
si moi aussi quand même donc ce week-end
où il le zéro pun le tournoi du club
donc le club lisboète de plaisir à les
hisser au stade l'opinion au palais des
sports de plaisir tout le week-end de 10
heures à 6 heures des matches qui vont
voir s'affronter les les meilleures
équipes dans les équipes de
principalement des yvelines huit équipes
dont l'équipe de plaisir et tout ceci
sera conclu par un match dimanche soir
entre des demeures des équipes du week
end est donc c'est un tournoi amical 1
c'est pas un tournoi la toile affaire la
fédération c'est un tournoi amical tout
à fait il est il est hors championnat
national repréciser pour ceux qui savent
pas eux-mêmes
oui voilà expliquait dans un petit peu
les voilà les conseils les concepts et
les principes de ce jeu tout puisque
c'est souvent dans l'idée générale le
frisbee sur la plage en fait voilà alors
l'usbl changement non plus spike non
c'est un sport de combat au sens
comme le rugby est un sport de combat
c'est un sport collectif donc avec un
frisbee un seul frisbee pour quand on
est à l'intérieur comme ce week-end 10
joueurs
cinq joueurs de chaque côté et seulement
le fin seulement le porteur du frisbee
ne peut pas bouger tout le reste de
l'équipe doit bouger ses coéquipiers
doivent se mettre en position de
recevoir une bonne passe ses 2
adversaires donc l'empêcher de faire une
bonne passe et vie c'est comme au rugby
il ya deux voilà enfin l'équipe à
marquer quand elle reçoit le frisbee
dans son en but tout comme au rugby
comme autre goût d'un mannequin psi et
lors c'est un sport qui est très méconnu
comme comme l'a soulevé un petit peu
wilfried c'est dur d'organiser des
tournois justement dans ce sport ou pas
non c'est pas forcément durant
virtuellement on a le soutien de la
mairie de plaisir en l'occurrence qui
chaque année nous nous prête maintenant
le palais des sports depuis que le
palais des sports a été construit voilà
nous on est on est pérenne maintenant
chaque année on fait un tournoi il ya du
tournoi régulièrement chaque week-end on
peut trouver un tournoi en france
ultimate et voilà vous pariez de sports
de combat il ya quand même on peut faire
des équipes mixtes ou c'est masculin
féminin bien rangé oui alors c'est un
sport mixte alors ce combat c'est un
très mauvais contact peut-être même pas
sport de contact justement c'est un
sport où tout contact et est une faute
et donc qui favorise la semi la mixité
alors parce que le
on va éviter les contacts donc mével
mesdemoiselles ou pascal et et la mixité
est possible elles mêmes elles mêmes
réels c'est à dire que nous on va en
championnat dans l'équipe une
avec des filles est évidemment il
forcément toujours il faut qu'il faut
que ses fils à s'auto si haut et court
aussi vite que des garçons ce qui sera
l'un verse avec les garçons et alors sur
ce sur ce sport comment on fait pour
être performant en situation de match et
efficace en fait l'ailé false bay alité
il ya beaucoup de technique parce que le
lancer de frisbee le frisbee à maîtriser
le frisbee est un objet qui se lancent
facilement sur la plage mais en fait il
ya beaucoup de choses sur la plage vous
verrez toujours ce qu'on appelle en fait
à un revers donc un lancer enroulez à
gauche un peu comme au tennis et le coup
droit lui nous publions à maîtriser mais
tout toujours du team être fini par le
maîtriser mais il ya cet aspect
technique évidemment il ya des lancers
un peu loeb gagne tout s'élance à
maîtriser après il ya des qualités qui
sont les qualités d'un joueur de banc
d'un jour de d'ultimate qui doit sauter
haut courir vite
beaucoup d'universités tout à fait mais
c'est très cardio c'est beaucoup plus
car dieu que qu'on se comprendre ce
qu'on peut penser beaucoup d'expiration
beau coup d'arrêt au tour je voudrais
que dans un mois ça fait je sais pas
exactement cela fait huit ans que je
joue par exemple le kenya joie de plage
auparavant maintenant je un ami qui m'a
dit viens voir ce sport j'ai dû lui
répondre que c'est un sport de plage et
puis j'ai essayé et j'avoue l'été ce que
j'ai dit et depuis lors sur ce tournoi
là sur le zéro plaisir à quelques
ambitions parce qu'on connaît très bien
la qualité de versailles notamment
oui alors les bonnes de type 2 équipes
attendues se seront versailles
certainement il ya paris qui vient avec
une collective de penser les gens de
saint germain comme j'étais beaucoup
l'équipe des yvelines pour ce qui est de
l'équipe de plaisir elle sera elle sera
mixte
en excuser moi mixte féminin masculin
ceci en niveau sert combat on va
intégrer beaucoup de beaucoup de nous
veut qu'on n'a pas pu forcément intégré
dans les équipes de championnat parce
qu'il était peut-être un peu un peu
faible pour aller en championnat fédéral
donc notre équipe sera de haut niveau
enfin ce rapt au niveau et sera
peut-être très performant tout ça sera
la surprise
justement c'est ce que vous me disiez
quand on prépare l'émission ce tournoi
c'est l'occasion pour vous notamment de
laisser sa chance à tout le monde en fin
de compte dans notre équipe mais on en
profite pour lancer non c'est beaucoup
de joueurs les joueurs un peu plus
expérimentés ils sont à l'organisation
on a besoin de tout de même pour pour
faire marcher le le tournoi et cette
dernière question ce sport qui est quand
même méconnu cc a l'air d'être un sport
moteur au niveau national mais dans les
yvelines
c'est il ya beaucoup de clubs présents
des clubs phares du championnat du
championnat tout à fait basséen un sport
pour des raisons que je ne maîtrise pas
totalement qui qui est un peu mais dans
les yvelines et un petit peu si on
vendait il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens en vendée dont beaucoup de gens en
yvelines elle et je crois que c'est un
peu parce que le premier club était de
le hot de la celle saint cloud où les
frisés liste de versailles ils se
battront entre c'est pas moi de trancher
ce débat très bien donc on se donne
rendez-vous ce week-end cesser les deux
jours un samedi dimanche de keller et
quelle heure 10h 18h très bien la balle
et de sport on suivra sarno merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau de
tv fixe ce soir est donc à ce week-end
pour les européennes même si on garde
nos petits points exactement
on a un bel équipement on va passer à
l'est ce crime wilfrid 1 ce week end
trappe disputait son quart de finale de
championnat de france par équipe de
fleuret face à rueil malmaison qui vise
le titre cette saison
la logique a été malheureusement
respecter pour les trappistes mais ils
sont bien accrochés
le défi était de taille pour les
escrimeurs trappistes en quarts de
finale du championnat de france par
équipes de fleurs et samedi dernier face
à hull élite de l'escrim française et
mondiale
vincent simon vainqueur du circuit
national victor sintès membre de
l'équipe de france
un pic et surtout bioshock troisième des
jeux olympiques de londres pour trappe
le bondissant benoît journée le premier
en piste
le numéro deux français lance idéalement
les saint quentinois cinq couches à 4
c'est alors que se présente lors du
second relais
le champion de france junior 2012 cédric
npd
fort d'une allonge impressionnante
l'espoir trappistes fait un festival en
contre et permet à trappes de mener 10
touches à 7
il va même réussir l'exploit de tenir
tête aux médaillés olympiques shea dans
le quatrième relais 19 partout les deux
équipes se tiennent en une deux touches
jusqu'à 30 29
c'est le moment choisi par wei et
vincent simon pour infliger un 5-1 aux
jeunes aiment kenney et le sud coréen
chol termine parfaitement au travail
score final 45-30 trappe s'arrête pour
la deuxième année consécutive en quarts
de finale pour la plupart des tiers qui
était en face effectivement on d
entraînement régulier voire quotidiens
de notre côté c'est pas c'est pas
forcément le cas on est parent on
s'entraîne pas autant donc forcément
physiquement au moment ça a été un peu
plus dur de notre côté et ils ont fait
la différence je pense aujourd'hui
physiquement parce que jusqu'à 30 chacun
chacun a tenu son rôle
et puis voilà donc forcément c'est un
peu un peu plus dur voilà donc on va
passer maintenant aux résultats
auparavant va revenir sur l'une des
informations de cette édition c'est du
rugby ils étaient en plateau avec nous
au tout à leur directeur technique du
club et puis entraîneur également
l'équipe senior qui se débrouille plutôt
bien
oui à rambouillet a fait la performance
du week-end il était en quart de finale
de playoffs pour monter à la division
d'honneur face à fontenay aux roses est
invaincu cette saison le club se
rendaient donc au stade du vieux moulin
rambouillet pour essayer d'être
d'accéder à ces divisions le contrat est
rempli
résumé de ce match dès le coup d'envoi
rambouillet veut marquer son territoire
les verts mettre plus d'intensité à
l'impact et perfore le premier rideau
fidesien
obtiennent une pénalité transformée par
camille maillot rim à la 20e minute de
jeu le même camille manioc riz profite
d'un cadrage d'école de match durant et
fils d'ali
dans un stade du vieux moulin chauffé à
blanc les rambolitains envoient du jeu
au large
au près tout y passe il mène logiquement
à la pause 13 heures
retour des vestiaires l'emprise rambo
liten s'accentue au fil des minutes le
deuxième essai est un modèle de relance
de maxime kaboré ne chante que passe en
revue cinq joueurs font plaisir
20 0 après la transformation de
l'excellent camille maillot riz auteur
d'un 4 sur 5 au pied et même à 13 contre
15 après deux cartons blancs
les joueurs d'éric david ou sont
euphoriques la muraille rambo liten est
infranchissable
il ajoute un quatrième essai en fin de
match par l'intermédiaire de romain
bausch man score final 31 3 la montée en
division d'honneur synonyme de
championnat de france est validé pour
embrouiller peu savoureux
on a bien entamé le match la marque et
de prato pour ma part j'ai vous créé
tease et les points des points au pied
rapidement ce qui nous ce qui nous a
fait ce qui nous a mis dedans rapidement
et le plus important c'est qu'on a été
solidaires aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui nous a tenus si on a tenu
bon toute la saison comme ça et
aujourd'hui on a une équipe à
rambouillet c'est plus important
non ces résultats du week-end place tout
d'abord au football en division
d'honneur versailles a est allé chercher
le match nul sur la pelouse du psg
actuel 4e de but partout en promotion
d'honneur guyancourt s'est à nouveau
incliné 1 2 buts à 0 à trembler 5e la
fin de saison s'annonce en roue libre
pour le sg dans la poule b de promotion
d'honneur contre-performance pour trappe
qui a concédé aussi le match nul 0 à 0
face à la lanterne rouge jouy-le-moutier
les trappistes n'ont plus gagné depuis
quatre journées 1 c'est un peu la reine
est incomplet pour pour trappe au
classement de cette poule b trappe
descend du podium du coup avec 42 points
un petit point de saint-cloud voilà le
classement qui apparaît mais pour rester
dans le wagon de tête les saint
quentinois de vote devront retrouver la
victoire à saint leu le week-end
prochain
en foot féminin la 10e 19e journée de
division 2 montigny et s'est inclinée
sèchement à domicile 3 0 face à
gravelines l'équipe du nord est bien la
bête noire des inimités n en huit
confrontations directes elles n'ont
jamais perdu face aux saint-quentinoise
du foot au foot us et les templiers
d'elancourt qui continue sur cette
excellente lancée
oui il retrouve l'élite cette année 5e
journée de championnat de france élite
et justement les templiers continuent
leur sans faute
les joueurs d'emmanuel charest se sont
imposés difficilement face aux
kangourous de pessac 28 27
ils ont ainsi pris leur revanche de la
finale de division 2 la saison passée
perdu en juin dernier face aux girondins
au classement est bien avec ce sans
faute évidemment ils encourent trône en
tête du championnat élite avec une
moyenne de points par match de plus de
30 points ce qui est relativement élevé
les templiers d'elancourt qui justifie
leur place un don parmi ce championnat
élite on se rappelle que leur montée
s'était joué sur tapis vert il ne devait
pas monter s'était incliné finalement
après un recours déposé pour des joueurs
adverses qui aurait pas dû être aligné
ils ont réussi à monter et il prouve
qu'ils ont toute leur place dans ce
championnat moins de contacts à présent
avec du badminton 10e journée de
nationale 3 et montigny s'est
logiquement incliné au paris lagardère
racing six matchs à 2 mais malgré la
défaite et bien lésigny montain assurent
leur maintien en championnat de france
puisqu'ils terminent à la 4e place de
leur poule et seulement les deux
derniers descendent les cinq et sixième
une dernière info le post it à la
natation et on n'en parle pas beaucoup
mais dans le département il ya beaucoup
de bons nageurs et une dizaine de jeunes
étaient présents championnats de france
espoirs à challans
son il ya dix jours et la versaillaise
chloé baril s'est classé 3e du 200 m
nage libre en deux minutes 04 secondes
seule nageuse du département d'ailleurs
à avoir décroché une médaille
merci anthony on vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 sport sur téléfilm n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à le commenter un saut 7,8
sport sur les réseaux sociaux et twitter
avec le hashtag ils savent il apparaît
en bas de votre écran le 7-8 sport tout
attaché et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs à lundi prochain
bonne soirée